guys ready to get weird tonight or what
fer Shur Oh looking straight girl a
bitch better have my honey Oh bear puns
I like those oh dude I can't believe you
spent your entire paycheck on that
jacket well I didn't spend my entire
paycheck I made 350 and Carl gave me a
deal on the coat 3:45 that's good that's
a good deal so you saved 5 bucks way to
go well I invested my savings in a
little bottle of ipecac it's the stuff
that makes you barf smart move basically
a get out of work free pass yeah makes
you barf dude cuz nothing makes me barf
it's weird I've got a stomach of Steel
Adam scientists developed that it would
make you vomit because scientists made
this yeah who believes in scientists
dude let me give this little tester ooh
hmm that's weird definitely don't feel
like barfing right now oh wait no I'm
barfing I'm barfing right now I'm not
barfing okay wait I'm barfing ohh I'm
barfing those scientists better check
your hypotenuse is dude Oh God